hey everyone we got a special episode of
take five today where we're going to
answer the top ten questions we hear
from customers wouldn't that make it
take ten and our first question is what
exactly is a customer engineer great
question in a sentence customer
engineers exist to help our customers
transform evolve and yes engineer their
business applications on Google Cloud we
do that by meeting with customers one on
one to understand their current state
and where they'd like to be in the
future we then work with customers to
navigate the best path to get them from
today to tomorrow help identify the
right technical solution within GCP
assemble a perfect concept collaborate
with them on the proper architecture and
design a migration plan to safely and
securely migrate their data to its
destination our ultimate goal is to help
customers be successful in Google cloud
platform and we really own that
end-to-end technical relationship
between Google cloud and you that's how
we roll question number two if I want to
run my application on GCP how do I
choose which product to use that's a
tough one because honestly it depends I
know that seems like a cop-out answer
but to recommend where you should be
running your application it's best to
fully understand your application
requirements GCP offers four primary
means of application hosting those main
compute engine kubernetes engine App
Engine and cloud functions Google
compute engine or GCE for short is our
infrastructure as a service offering
which allows you to create fully managed
and customizable VMs for running your
apps if you're interested in running a
containerized application google
kubernetes engine or gke might be the
best option because gke is our fully
managed and hardened container
orchestration and management service if
managing infrastructure isn't your jam
checkout app engine which is Google's
platform as a service solution and lets
developers completely focus on building
great applications without the
management overhead of dealing with
servers or configuration deployments
finally cloud functions is Google's
event-driven and surveillance platform
that only runs your code in response to
event driven triggers the best news is
you can also pick a combination of
computing offerings so you don't have to
just
why on one hey I got one now that we
know about application hosting my up
obviously needs storage question three
how do I decide where to store my data
well there are many fully managed
offerings here for that data that's
either structured unstructured
transactional or relational persistent
disk offers block storage that's
suitable for VMs and any kind of
containers like Google compute engine or
kubernetes engine as you mentioned cloud
storage is used for object storage and
can store streaming multimedia or custom
data analytics pipelines or even backups
and disaster recovery and then cloud
BigTable is a no sequel wide column
database that's suitable for real-time
access and any kind of analytics for
clothes that need low latency and high
throughput readwrite access cloud
datastore is a no sequel document
database for web and mobile applications
and cloud sequel is a managed my sequel
and Postgres database service cloud
spanner is a mission-critical relational
database service with transactional
consistency and global scale and Club
bakery is a fully managed enterprise
data warehouse with sequel syntax and
real-time response for ad hoc querying
lastly we have a number of databases and
storage used for firebase our mobile and
web app hosting platform ok a penny on
the poor I think we took a wrong turn
oh well onward with question number four
everyone is talking about machine
learning these days but I just don't
know where and how to get started what's
the best way to get started with ml if
not a data scientist or robot
well Google wants to democratize AI and
make it accessible and useful for
enterprises and developers we offer
ready to use models so you can focus on
the application and not to science using
our machine learning REST API it's quite
simple Google Cloud provides fully
trained machine learning models for
vision video intelligence speech
translation natural language processing
and these are extremely to use if you
are a developer familiar with rest
so the mlle pis are pre-trained on
google datasets and ready to go anyone
that knows how to call a REST API can
integrate with them from their
applications if you want to train your
own
data sets instead of relying on Google's
data then cloud auto ml allows you to
create models specific to your domain no
programming experience or machine
learning experience is required you
simply identify your training data and
labels and Cloud Auto ml does the rest
last we have the world's most popular ml
framework tensorflow and this is
available as a managed service called
cloud ml this is for those with via
reticle machine learning knowledge and
those who are comfortable writing code
check out the blog post learn tensorflow
and deep learning without a PhD if
you're a developer interested in this
option sounds like Google has a lot of
experience with big data and machine
learning question 5 if my business is
running on TCP does Google and analyze
the data I've stored in the cloud not at
all
many people are concerned with their
data and privacy is a big deal for
Google as well as every other company
our focus is on making sure only you
have access to your data not only does
Google not read or analyze your data we
also encrypt everything and give you the
ability to use your own encryption keys
to make sure you're the only one who can
read it this applies to all of the
Google cloud services thanks everyone
for watching join us in the next episode
of the remaining top 5 questions
[Music]